hello welcome to the debate on Sky News
I'm Martin Stanford here's our take on
developments brought together from
America the UK and around the world
that's why I stand here as confident as
I have ever been that the state of our
union is strong state of what union a
verdict on the president's valedictory
address and powerball crazy but can a
little flutter ever be completely just
for fun next over town is 19
well it was his last big set piece
occasion as president did he make a
lasting impression in a moment we will
speak to Professor Jerry mayor of George
Mason University for his take on the
last big speech of the Obama era but
first let's bring in our regular guest
the Democrat commentator Geoffrey
Robinson is standing by a New York and
conservative commentator Armstrong
Williams is in Washington DC Geoffrey
what did you make of a speech I thought
it was one of the best features of his
presidency I thought he really hit it
out of the park I liked it when he
announced a new national initiative to
fight cancer and put instead the Joe
Biden was going to be at in Mission
Control and and at one point Biden
turned to Paul Ryan sitting next to him
and said I didn't expect that he was
genuinely surprised I liked it when he
took on the the Republicans who denies
science by San climate change by saying
when the Russians put sputnik into space
60 years ago we didn't deny it was up
there and what we did was we took it as
a challenge and put a man on the moon 12
years later saying in other words we can
beat climate change and I like the fact
that he used used the analogy with
health care saying the Republicans don't
want health care and yet the only people
that he knows who have 30 year job with
health care and a retirement package are
all sitting in this chamber a direct hit
at the at the Republicans i particularly
like one word that he used which was
fiction which pretty much sums up the
republican stance on everything and if
you don't believe me listen to the
fiction from armstrong well we can
discuss all those points in a minute
armstrong do you think it gives him a
purpose for these next few months oh he
has a purpose that is obvious he's out
on the campaign trail as we speak
touting his uh what he considered to be
in his own mind his extraordinary State
of the Union speech you know the
president admitted that Congress is more
divided and there's more rancor than
ever he mentioned the fact that maybe
Lincoln and Roosevelt would have taken a
different approach and in a closing
moment of the speech he almost allowed
himself that takes some flame
in from ranka and the divisiveness he
also talked about the failures in his
own way of the Islamic state and the
rise of Isis and the fact that things
are not better off in the Middle East it
was almost an indictment of his own
foreign policy and he admitted the fact
that he would be leaving the next
administration burden and saddled with
those issues that can only get worse
unless we confront them in a very
meaningful way what is interesting
though what he echoed without college
donald trump's name was echoed by gov
the governor of south carolina nikki
Haley they did not want the president I
want to call his name but they talked
about the divisiveness about what he
said about Muslims and how he's very
defensive in his remarks and that's not
who we are as Americans I don't know
whether President Obama was doing this
because he really cares about the
dissidents in this country whether he's
really trying to throw a bone to Hillary
Clinton who's now struggling to maintain
her lead against candidate Bernie
Sanders which is almost shocking if you
think about the fact that Bernie Sanders
is gaining on her in the polls I'm
strong let's just run that clip shall we
just before we hear from Professor mayor
let's hear the section of the speech
where the president attacked the attacks
on muslims when politicians insult
Muslims whether abroad or our fellow
citizens when a mosque is vandalized or
a kid is called names and doesn't make
us safer that's not telling you what
telling it like it is it's just wrong it
diminishes us in the eyes of the world
it makes it harder to achieve our goal
it betrays who we are as a country
well professor Jeremy mayor joins us now
from George Mason University's School of
policy government and international
affairs professor that was an attack on
Donald Trump wasn't it it absolutely was
and the question is was he attacking
Trump in order to elevate Trump
strategically or was he trying to really
reach out to Republicans and have them
come to their senses what do you think
of the two well I think he really is
being sincere i think he is frightened
by the popularity of Trump I mean we're
talking about a man who has led one of
our two major parties now consistently
for months and months and months and
he's still leading in the polls
nationally I think the president really
wants to wake up a large portion of
Americans to the threat that Trump poses
do you think he will find any sympathy
in Republican inclined voters by saying
this well that's the problem is he's so
radioactive among Republicans that Trump
is only helped by Obama attacking which
is why I think the president didn't
mention him by name what could hurt
Trump was the republican response by
Governor Haley that type of persuasive
more gentle republicanism might hurt
Trump if it's consistently echoed by
other figures in the party but if you
note very few Republicans took up that
banner that today Armstrong let me bring
you in on that point because you
mentioned it as well do you think this
attitude of America to the Muslim faith
internally and worldwide will remain a
big issue in this forthcoming campaign
it is the issue you cannot escape it
it's all around us every time you turn
around almost there's a terrorist attack
so we're in the world and what is really
interesting though is that in order for
the president are for the Republicans
message to really be effective with the
American people because it's obvious
that the Republican establishment that
feels just as strongly about what this
divisiveness as the President himself
you've got to balance it out
talking about there is extremism there
is this terrorism that is a threat and
Muslims are our brothers and we should
not paint them with a broad brush but we
do expect them to condemn this kind of
behavior and the president having
someone like care who it has been known
untraceable that they fund some of these
terrorist organizations and tighten them
as some organization that we should
admire respect it could easily become an
ad for someone like a Donald Trump they
could backfire and then also Donald
Trump is very clever I've never seen
anybody who is masterful as he is and
turning the tables on the media and even
he and many of the people are just grown
over this election because of the
establishment the president is
establishment governor hate gillians the
establishment he could certainly take
this kind of message from the president
last night to say they're against me and
use it as an ad and using as more few
for him to continue what he's doing with
the more range of support because listen
his support is not just isolated to
Republicans they're Democrats who were
privately tell you that they like what
Trump is saying but they just wish he
would say it better and gently in that
context how does the more moderate voice
ever get hurt during this forthcoming
election process it doesn't it simply
doesn't and as for as for Armstrong's
moderate Republicans you won't find us
moderate Democrats you won't find a
sober one supporting supporting Trump
you hardly find a big swath of real
Republicans not his right-wing
constituents but the real Republican
Party there are sixty to sixty-five
percent who were saying no to Donald
Trump as opposed to the 35 who were
supporting him and when push comes to
shove he's going to have a real hard
time getting elected he'll have a hard
time getting the nomination because the
mainstream Republican party doesn't want
him and the part the the the country
will reject him the point is that
Governor Haley is is pretending to be a
moderate so she can get on the on the
ticket with somebody his vice
presidential candidate don't forget she
was elected by the Tea Party she's a
right-wing conservative bigoted governor
who has absolutely denied most of her
citizens there
writes the things like health care she's
as disgraceful as the rest of the
Republican governors so we're not going
to paint governor Haley as a heroine the
one thing she did take down the
Confederate flag that's to her credit
but she's done nothing else to to
deserve any praise III think I think the
professor is illustrating exactly how
the Democratic Party is becoming almost
as crazy and extreme as the Republican
Party in response that kind of rhetoric
about Governor Haley is simply out of
bounds she's not some wild-eyed Tea
Party crazy she's taken to some very
conservative stances but in the context
of the modern Republican Party she's
very much in the establishment and I
think she'd be a very smart choice for
Rubio as a vice presidential candidate
or Kasich Rubio and Kasich don't stand a
chance Rubio is running for high school
prom chairman and Kasich couldn't get
elected because he did the right thing
when it came to Medicare in the people
of the state no she's a tea party
candidate a wolf in sheep's clothing
yeah you're a fool if you think
otherwise let me ask the professor about
the nature of the discourse here we've
seen it in the month so far and it's not
getting any better as in the aftermath
of the president's final State of the
Union address is there any place in the
discourse in the next few months for a
more moderate inclusive attitude to
politics in America generally yeah I
think we're waiting for the ross perot
moment over nafta and many of you won't
recall but in 1993 al gore took on ross
perot who was a populist certainly no
Donald Trump he was a much more urbane
and sophisticated person intellectually
but he was also kind of a blowhard on
trade and Al Gore sat down with him on a
television show and in 45 minutes
dismantled the man uh it revealed him to
be uninformed and it might happen in a
Republican debate when it gets down to
just two or three people in Trump Trump
can survive when it's 10 people or eight
people on stage but he has so little
substance to his policy positions that
when it gets down to just a two person
debate I hope that America will see that
the man lacks substance and is simply an
archetype of hate let me just pause now
and focus on a moment when the President
reiterated his belief that ISIL should
be fought on the ground if necessary if
this Congress is serious about winning
this war and wants to send a message to
our troops and the world authorize the
use of military force against ISIL take
a vote
if you doubt America's commitment or
mine to see the justice is done just ask
Osama bin Laden well professor that did
rather serve to indicate how difficult
the president this president has found
doing many things completely or
particular these odds with Congress on
so many matters well I think
specifically on that point it's congress
that has dropped the ball they don't
want to take a vote on use of force
because they don't want to take
responsibility for anything that the
president does or does not do if he
asked for support and they don't give it
then they're to blame if he should have
done it and if he asked for supporting
they give it then they're to blame if
what he does goes wrong so this prep
this Congress primarily on the
Republican side but also some of the
Democrats don't want to take a vote that
will be hard they'd rather Obama just
take all the responsibility it's a very
few senators like Tim Kaine who've stood
up and said no we're the Congress we
should take this vote I'm strong what do
you think about the military action
question look III think the professor
and and I might just find common ground
under sir and it was she saying yeah
that there is truth to it but there's a
bigger story here most of our generals
at home and abroad or this to the
president whether it's Republicans and
Democrats in Congress caution against us
putting troops on the ground why because
ISIL and Isis would like nothing more
than the American troops on the ground
so they could kidnap them torture them
and make them a part of their new videos
and it's just not a good idea to have
Westerners fighting on the ground
against Muslims if you're going to
create that kind of scenario they should
fight against each other you should use
the Kurds and the other options that we
have in that region we just they just
don't think and listen I am as a
journalist and a broadcast on other
conversations with these generals and
they make it very clear that putting
American troops on the ground will
backfire and become something that the
American people cannot stomach because
of what I
this would like to do with captured
Americans to make an example out of them
I agree absolutely with what Armstrong
saying but to be clear what the
president asked for a use of force does
not mean ground troops it simply means
that our ongoing action in Syria and
Iraq against Isis would then have the
support of the Congress right now the
president is doing it under the
authority of the use of force
resolutions that authorized Iraq and the
use of force resolution that authorized
the war against Al Qaeda on September 14
2001 so we need a new use of force
resolution to firmly say that the
legislative body is behind the fight
against Isis Jeffrey yes absolutely I
agree with both of them it's nice to see
that Armstrong suddenly gotten religion
because less than a month ago he was
sitting on the same program saying the
only way to win is to send in ground
forces I mean obviously it's not the way
to win you need if ground forces go in
it's got to be Muslim Arab ground forces
from the Arab nation Saudi in particular
Egypt perhaps a few other countries who
are supposed to be our coalition
partners in this but it would be suicide
to send in American troops and I don't
think anybody wants it the Republican
Congress is simply shirking its duty as
it has for the last eight years don't
forget that the now leader of the Senate
then minority leader of the Senate said
on the first day of Obama's presidency
my job is to make sure he's a one-term
president that's disgraceful and and
typical of what the Republican attitude
towards his president has been could I
just get wasn't it take for each of you
if I could on the cancer job he's given
to Joe Biden that's a bit of visionary
thinking Jeffrey isn't it set to set
something I supposed to inspire people
yes and it's it's reminiscent of
Kennedy's putting a man on the moon
speech what he did especially with Biden
and it's now come out that when bo took
ill Obama went to Biden right away and
said if you need any financial help
we're here to help with whatever the
costs are he did that as a personal
friendship to to Joe Biden who's been a
loyal servant of the American people and
a great vice president hopefully that
will would be a rallying call it would
be great 10 years from now to say we did
it we've solved the problem yeah I'm
some give me some legacy wouldn't it
you know what those kinds of moments are
very important for them for the optics
because you know while people may think
that the binds are wealthy and they
probably are is that about whether the
binds have wealth and that it's the fact
that the president shows us hard he
shows his compassion for a friend who
lost someone in a very devastating way
and so it reminds the American people
despite our politics and our differences
we must find the best in each other and
how each other left each other
especially when it comes to these kinds
of crisis is like health and so many of
Americans and people around the world
die a cancer the day and unfortunately
we're no closer to a cure than we were
10 or 15 years ago and professor I guess
with so many things unresolved gun
control not really sorted Guantanamo
still working although he did say let's
see if we can shut it in the next year
if America could make real advancements
in the cure of cancer that would be
something for the Obama legacy would it
not it would but I hate to be the skunk
at the garden party on this point but
he's not the first president to commit
to fighting cancer in a state of the
union other presidents have said we'll
spend billions on this and cancer is a
very tough thing to crack I hope it ends
up like Kennedy and the man on the moon
in ten years but where are we have a
national cancer institute we have the
NIH we're already spending billions on
the cancer fight if what this speech
means is that he can get Congress to
commit another billion another two
billion over the next year or two that
will mean something but I don't think
Joe Biden is going to lead us to a great
breakthrough in the next 11 months thank
you very much indeed professor thank you
now as we record this show it's
Wednesday afternoon so we don't know the
result of the latest roll over in a
lottery called Powerball an executive
from the Texas Lottery said that at peak
traffic they were selling 1.2 million
dollars worth of tickets every MIT when
it was last wrong when the cross they
didn't get the result now statisticians
have put the chances of a win tonight as
similar to flipping a coin and getting
heads 28 times in a row so small is it
worth it and in any case is it healthy
well Keith white is from the National
Council on problem gambling is there any
such thing Keith as a casual flutter
like this big lottery there is certainly
such a thing as a casual flutter we know
that for the vast majority of people our
lottery is a recreational activity our
concern is of course people the reasons
that people play so if you're playing as
it means investment if you're playing as
a means about paying the bills well if
you're playing most importantly it's a
means of escaping pain or stress in your
life those are all signs that you may
have a gambling problem and does the one
necessarily lead to the other everyone
starts out for fun no one starts out to
become addicted and we know how and why
you start is important so if you start
if you receive a lottery ticket as a
gift as a child it later on in life even
more you if you have a game any problem
and they're likely to have a severe
problem and in that sense Keith can any
one of us fall prey to a gambling
problem or rather certain personality
types which are more likely to have a
problem with gambling for most people
it's Louis and we do know conversely
that there are people who are at high
risk in those groups include young males
between 18 to 24 people who are using
and abusing other substances other
addictive activities and especially
people with a family history of
addiction so in other words if you had a
problem gambler in your immediate family
you're seven times
more likely to gain from yourself if you
had an alcoholic or drug addict in your
in your family your your rates are also
higher so we know that it's better us
out it's good for psychology it's your
it's your environment it's how I Uganda
and there is certainly genetic risk
factors um I was reporting from Las
Vegas on another program last week so of
course that is a gambling den isn't it
there are the horses what type of
gambling is more difficult to manage
compared to say a flutter on the lottery
when you look at the structural
characteristics of the games those
really determine some of the more
addictive factors in the nose intersect
with the individual's own bowels in
psychology but again for most people
slot machines you know high speed of
play very very large prices often
frequent suika twins are those seem to
be factors that are associated with game
addiction into the majority of people
are seeking home let me bring in
Armstrong and Jeffrey who are back with
us for now Armstrong let me go to you
first I don't know do you use the
lottery do you have a little flutter on
the lottery or is it not something that
interests you know I can you not play a
billion gobble lottery I mean are you
kidding me I meanwhile the chances are
probably one in a zillion I mean you may
just have the number I mean some people
may say is two dollars but look I don't
think you have a choice but the player
Jeffry G do you ever buy the lottery
tickets you do we clear just on these
big occasions yeah well first of all
Keith's message about compulsive
gambling is very very very important
because it's a serious problem I'm a
truly serious problem with tragic
consequences and needs to be addressed
yeah I play in fact every week I put my
two dollars down on a powerball and I
actually choose the correct numbers it's
the Powerball people draw the wrong
number but I figured it out this time I
took real interest once it's passed a
billion dollars in its up to a billion
five now and probably will go higher by
the time it's drawn tonight i figured
out i can guarantee how to win I mean I
worked it out and mathematically
you cannot lose and here's your solution
the odds are if you choose every single
number in every combination the odds are
about 261 something like that too and 61
million to one so that two bucks a shot
for 520 million dollars if you happen to
have scared change you can pull every
number and a guaranteed to win the 1.5
billion dollars the problem is that
Armstrong is going to spend 260 or 520
million dollars and you can have to
share it with him in the end it's a
loser and gamblers always lose never
ever winch no gambler no compulsive
gamblers ever come out ahead ever Keith
where are you in terms of the education
because the education of the young is a
mammoth challenge because I suppose a
gambling taking a chance taking a risk
that's part of growing up isn't it DNA I
think Americans have always been really
taking risks we've been sergers and
worse and entrepreneurs so I think it's
it's baked into the American psyche and
I think that serves us well in a lot of
areas I was given and especially with
state sponsor gambling it can be a
little bit tricky so we do we urge that
there be broad public education and
prevention and treatment programs but
unfortunately it's unbeatable in a
number of states there is no funding
whatsoever so there's states to Ricky
and hundreds of millions of dollars from
there to police every year and not
putting a single penny of it back into
the venture treatment the federal
government doesn't routinely spend a
single set and so they're huge gaps in
our safety system Jeffrey there's a
problem isn't it really because it's
kind of as you is you're intimating it
so of course it's a manly thing it's an
expected thing of course you're going to
have a little go at this but for those
who fall between the cracks and get into
trouble with it there isn't much
sympathy it's a disease actually and
there should be a lot of sympathy and
there are things that you can do them
Gamblers Anonymous is a terrific
organization much like Alcoholics
Anonymous and people have a problem
really should seek help as a journalist
many many many years ago 40 years ago I
covered a meeting of gamblers anonymous
and I can tell you is the most
depressing night of my life
because normal ordinary people SAT there
and explain their story and said I hit
my little old grandmother over the head
to steal her television so I could put a
bet down on some horses one and
immediately put that money back in
because winning is not what it's all
about it's the rush it's the gambling
and lost the money it tragic stories and
people who have that problem need to get
help i might point out the George Jeb
Bush when he was governor of Florida
started the state lotto in Florida
promising to put that money into
education and he did what he did was he
took the state budget for education took
that money out of the budget and
substituted a lot of money so nobody won
absolutely nobody won and can it be a
time like this Keith that actually
triggers that person in need to reach
out to somebody like yourself this is a
very teachable moment and it's Jeffrey
said yeah this is a conversation we have
365 days a year but if it's just a bit
if it's just the conversation that we
can reach people now with it with this
hijack there is an enormous opportunity
to help people at the same time let's
say you're trying to recover from a game
in common just the bombardment of
messages are you know the permitted with
necklace promotion Cantor the relapse so
I think for someone who in recovery the
phone this is a really really really
tough time and in the longer this
crescendo goes the more pressure it is
on them because many of them feel
they're only one better way to winning
everything back and a life-changing
jackpot like this we think well I've
already lost millions of dollars why
shouldn't i change my heart aren't I do
you know I need to be do I have to be
due and so again it's a teachable moment
our reps that is mcp Jeffrey org it's
almost been crushed by the increased
traffic our helpline we had 276,000
calls last year to that line alone it's
800 522 4700 and that I had one is seen
also a huge surge I this this week Keith
white good to talk to you thank you very
much indeed thank you mom yes and that's
it for this edition of the debate you
can continue watching sky news on apple
TV on roku and catch up and of course at
Sky News calm
until next time goodbye